وزير الخارجات
الاوكرانيبا ضيف شرف على الدوره 29
المؤتمر السنوي للسفراء الفرنسيين فرنسا
قالت لنا ستواصل لاوكرانيا طالما لازم
الامر وفقا لتصريحات وزيره الخارجيه
كاترين كورونا
تفاصيل حول المساعدات الفرنسيه التي كانت
حاضره في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
يتحدث عن اهميه التسليح واعطاء المزيد من
المساعدات لاوكرانيا لنتذكر انه في مجال
المساعدات مجتمعه اي المساعدات الانسانيه
العسكريه والماليه فرنسا قدمت لاوكرانيا
بين بدايه العام 2022
والعام الحالي تحديدا شهر ايار مايو العام
الحالي ما قيمته مليار فاصله
من المليار من اليوروهات
والمجتمعا الاتحاد الاوروبي قدم رقما
كبيرا للغايه تجاوز السبعه وسبعين مليار
يورو نتحدث عن الاتحاد الاوروبي مجتمعا
فرنسا بدورها قدمت اضافه الى المساعدات
الانسانيه والتدريب الذي يجري في بولندا
بمساعده 150 مدربا فرنسيا قدمت ايضا
العديد من المعدات العسكريه مثل اسلحه
الخاصه بمراقبه الاجواء اي الردارات
المتقدمه انظمه
والعربات العسكريه وغيرها ولهذا هذه
النقطه الاولى التي تتحدث عنها كوليبا ولم
يغفل ان يبدا مؤتمره الصحفي بدعوه كافه
قطاع التسليح الفرنسي الى زياره معرض
الاسلحه الذي سيقام في اوكرانيا الخليفه
المقبل طيب ليس مردود الفعل على تراجع
تاييد ربما الامريكيين تحديدا للد في
الفتره الاخيره هذا سؤال وجه في نهايه
المؤتمر الصحفي تحديدا لكوليبا لنتذكر ان
استطلاع عن الراي نشرته شبكه
ان 55% من الامريكيين لا يؤيدون زياده في
الدعم تجاه اوكرانيا خمسه
من الامريكيين يؤيدون زياده في الدعم وهذا
ما يعد تراجعا قال التالي سواء في اوروبا
وامريكا لا نحس بخفض الدعم نسمع اصواتا
ترتفع في امريكا واحيانا في اوروبا الامر
مفهوم في الولايات المتحده لانه مرتبط
ببدايه العمليه الانتخابيه لكن هذا بحسب
دائما وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني سيمر وسوف
نتغلب على هذا ونجد حلولا لان اوكرانيا
بكل بساطه تخوض حربا عادله وبطوليه
وتستحق الدعم هل تم التطرق الى خطه السلام
يعني
كان هناك الرئيس الاوكراني منذ ميزانات
قطار سابقا هذه هل تم التطرق العشر
الشهيره للرئيس زينسكي بالطبع تم التطرق
الى الامر في عده محاور لكن ربما الاجابه
الابرز كانت على لسان كوليبا ماذا قال
كوليبا وهذا يقول كثيرا عن الموقف
الاوكراني المفاوضات مع بوتين لها اجابه
واضحه اسالوا بريكوجين الذي كان على خلاف
وخض مفاوضات ناجحه ووضع حدا للخلاف مع
بوتين وتلقى ضمانات مع هذا قتله بوتين
دائما بحسب كوليبا ولا يجب الظن انه في اي
نوع من المفاوضات سيتصرف بوتين غير ذلك
دائما بحسب وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني وهذا
يظهر مره اخرى انعدام الثقه الهائل بين
الطرفين وتحديدا من قبل الجانب الاوكراني
تجاه روسيا في هذه المرحله تحديدا طيب
سؤال الاخير يعني
القاره الافريقيه تطرقت اليها ايضا
الوزيره واحتلت بشكل عام كبيرا في هذا
المؤتمر كان لفتا التركيز على مساله
ايقاف روسيا للعمل باتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب
مره اخرى عباره اخرى بارزه لوزير
الاوكراني يتحدث عن
تمارسها روسيا على الدول الافريقيه في
اشاره الى السلسله الشهيره التي تظهر
تجويع فريق لفئه معينه من الناس اذا بحسب
كليبا هذا هو دور التي تقوم به
روسيا لكنه قال انها اوكرانيا تسعى الى
ايجاد طرق بحريه
بديله تبعد الابتزاز الروسي النقطه
الثانيه التي كان فيها سؤال حول مدى
امكانيه فرنسا لاعب دور في هذه النقطه وفي
العلاقه مع الدول الافريقيه في وقت تتعرض
فرنسا لانتقادات كثيره اجابت هنا وزياره
الخارجيه الفرنسيه قالت فرنسا ملتزمه ربما
فرنسا ليست الطرف الوحيد الذي يقوم بمد
جسور مع دول افريقيه مع دول من امريكا
اللاتينيه وحتى مع الصين لكن فرنسا ملتزمه
للغايه بامكانيه الوصول الى حلول تشمل
كافه الاطراف وبالتعاون مع كافه الاطراف
شكرا جزيلا لك ميساء